he's an American businessman CEO and
founder of Under Armour he has a network
of 3.2 billion dollars in 2012 he was
named number 3 on Forbes 40 under 40
list he's Kevin Plank and here are his
top 10 rules for success I think we
control our own destiny and so whether
David makes it or not has nothing to do
with sort of the size of the mighty
Goliath and if you're thinking like that
you'll probably always be able to find a
reason and frankly an excuse in some
lame answer as to why you can't win
because the markets aren't good I was in
the middle of this and you know through
2000 in the first crash and people are
going into markets terrible markets
terrible like I'm selling stretchy
t-shirts not nothing to do with the
financial crisis it's like sports are
going to be played and kids will wear it
or they won't and you know I think
anybody can you can look and find but I
challenge all of us to say stop finding
reasons to find and make excuses that
you know we affectionately Under Armor
call loser talk and I don't know you
you've got to just will it and and focus
on making habit there's a saying it was
actually attributed to the chairman of
Sony several years ago and it said that
perfection is the enemy of innovation
perfection is the enemy of innovation
and what that effectively means is that
how many entrepreneurs are sitting out
there with a great idea tinkering in
their garage right now waiting to get
this concept out there waiting to get
the idea out there but it's not quite
perfect yet the criteria that we use at
Under Armour whenever we look at a
product or whether we decide to do
something is that it must be better than
what's currently available in the market
it may not be the perfect vision of what
we have but sometimes you have to get in
the game in order to make it improve
don't ever settle don't ever let a
product just be okay or just barely good
enough but I challenge all of us to
think in that way as you could
leadership is required it's in the word
it's to lead and it's lead by example
and it's haven't set a vision and all
those kind of things that you need but
it's to make sure that you never limit
the idea or the opportunity
you know what I find myself doing more
often than not is ensuring that we have
enough runway in front of us ensuring
that we are thinking about things big
enough because you can come complacent
your job is to push your company but
it's not just to show up and say I want
20% more more important you need to set
an expectation and set a path in a
vision that allows people to achieve
that at the same time I can remember
those early days when you want to be big
you're constantly projecting yourself as
a company you're going to be and whether
it was 1996 and we're starting out with
$17,000 in revenues and you've got that
you know we're going to beat those those
bad guys whatever your industry is
whoever the big one you can point it and
it's it's good to have a nemesis Luke
Skywalker wouldn't be him if you didn't
have Darth Vader and so you needed a
side and define who's your Darth Vader
and then you typically put a put them
over the dartboard you throw darts at
them you think about them but you
understand that in order if you'd be
successful it's got nothing to do with
anybody else and frankly the games that
we all are typically playing are not
zero sum games either and so in order
for us to win which is still part of the
ethos and philosophy we take it under
armor today it's not a matter
necessarily of someone else losing in
sporting goods the PI was about this big
and you'd look and people were
constantly trying to take Shara from
each other back and forth and when we
got into it and the thing that allowed
us for our breakthrough was we
effectively went and made our own PI and
with that we created this new category
and it gave us the legs to think about
not necessarily how we compared to
somebody else but the opportunity that
we had I think when comparing what we
were doing versus compared to what we
felt the opportunity was I was lucky
enough to not listen to people I was
lucky enough to use this statement that
I framed my thinking back then and
hopefully still today I was always smart
enough to be naive enough to not know we
could not accomplish
I was always smart enough to be naive
enough to not know we could not
accomplish why not us because anybody
smart I talked to said are you're crazy
you're going to go against these
behemoths in this industry you know how
big these other brands are the guys out
west the guys in Germany it's a
dangerous category the fact is I didn't
care all I knew is that I was gonna make
the world's greatest t-shirt
and it started out making the world's
greatest t-shirt for football players
that quickly grew to baseball players
lacrosse players hockey players on and
on and on great product always wins and
we are fortunate to have that and so the
hardest thing that any organization has
is getting the people right right and so
I'm very fortunate because the first
decision that I made was to hire my
first partner which was Kip folks right
and getting Kip in and then I trusted
that you know Kip would hire two great
people and they would hire three great
people and all along the way you know
you get to establish and you get to
build a culture and you know that's
something that takes a long long time to
do and it's something that you'd better
be good at because you're never done
particularly in a growing company I
would tell you that the number one key
to underarmour success to any new
company success plain and simple is
focus and the thing lost in sort of the
first ten years that we don't get credit
for at Under Armour was that from 1996
to really 2000 we had one product great
entrepreneurs take one product and say
we're going to be great for this and
most importantly we're going to be
famous for one thing and that is like
the greatest advice I can give you
because so often you get caught up with
trying to keep up with the Joneses and
going but they're doing this and they're
doing that it's like they're also like
150 times your size you're not in the
same league you need to become great at
one thing and that's where Under Armour
when the first five years it was where
today we're on I think it's over the
60th different iteration of that first
short sleeve wicking compression t-shirt
that I made and so often you see people
going you've got to make a long sleeve
you've got to make one for womens you've
got to make one here and I was like I
have to make this product great and we
literally sold it and made it and made
it over and over and it was never
frankly done and that's what allowed us
from that t-shirt and like you should
make shoes you should make shoes you
should make shoes and I'm going we're
not ready to make shoes and it wasn't
until 2006 when we finally launched
shoes 10 years into our company and then
frankly it's not even really until now
and getting better ten years after
beginning to make them and eight years
after selling them we're I think we're
really beginning to see scale in the
ability to be great
in Footwear and it took us becoming
famous and one thing first before you
just start running off on a number of
ideas that aren't the most important
thing to you know the success of your
business you know speed and the ability
to make fast decisions you know smarts
is something you never want to turn your
your back on but if I had to choose I
would probably take speed especially in
starting a business and being an
entrepreneur and there's so many great
ideas right now that are sitting in a
basement or an attic where the
entrepreneur is just timid or afraid to
get out to market because they think
it's not perfect it's not right it's not
ready to go and one thing you learn in
business is that version 2 is always
going to be better the version 1 you can
say I want to wait I want to hold back
on I'm just not ready but to go and to
move forward and I've had to make
decisions as a company that I didn't
believe were always the perfect
decisions but I believe they were
probably the best decisions for us as a
company and us as a brand and sometimes
that better decision is just making a
decision that it is absolutely in any
good company there must be a fight like
family mentality where you sit at that
table and every ideas out there and
whether it's me pushing them because I'm
trying to get my company ready for the
scale of growth that we're about to see
and trying to prepare and get yourself
in front of that because many of you
will be faced where typically in any
business you're one is lagging the other
I say one is that you sort of front end
you have back end and there's this
constant natural tension between people
saying with all the facilities we can't
do it we have to and I'm one of those
that believes in like you've got to sell
it first you've got to push it and we're
going to figure out how to make it we're
going to figure out how to get there
and there's times where we've gotten too
big another side but the bigger box the
bigger warehouse you build you're
typically filling it with stuff you
don't need if there's any two things and
it kill you in business it is people and
it is inventory and be incredibly
sensible to both of them and for the
entrepreneurs in here that may be in a
fundraise or going in a fundraise or
thinking about a fundraise and it's the
worst thing I think I see is companies
new companies that become perpetual
money raisers if you need money why
don't you do yourself a favor you keep
the equity and if you need money go sell
the stuff in your warehouse go sell your
product and if you can't sell your
product then there's probably something
wrong with the business because there's
nothing more fundamental than is someone
willing to take cash out of their pocket
and
in your hand and receive your good and
if you can't answer that question of
does your product sell you need to have
a faster conversation if you are sitting
on an idea whether it's on your laptop
whether it's in your garage whether it's
in your basement whether it's in the
back of your car give it a shot right
and the best advice I ever received find
out if your product and sell
don't let anybody talk you out of it
give it a chance try make it happen this
is our greatest asset as a nation and
one that we have to continue to
encourage you don't have to go broke you
don't have to bet everything on it but
you can start one day at a time taking a
chance and seeing if you two can build a
great company thank you so much for
watching I made this video because
Keegan TG asked me to so there's a
famous entrepreneur you want me to
profile next leave it in the comments
below and I'll see what I can do I'd
also love to know which of the top ten
rules meant the most to you is going to
have the biggest impact for you leave it
in the comments below and I'm going to
join in the discussion thank you guys so
much for watching continue to believe
and I'll see you soon